awkward scenes embarrassing Prosthetics
and Jennifer coolidge's very real
reservations unsurprisingly the White
Lotus is just as exciting behind the
scenes the White Lotus fans were excited
when Parks and Recreation star Aubry
Plaza decided to join the show for its
second season Plaza stars as Harper a
lawyer vacationing in Sicily with her
husband Ethan his college friend Cameron
and Cameron's wife Daphne after arriving
at the resort tensions start to arise as
Harper quickly realizes that she
dislikes her husband's friends
throughout the season Harper's
judgmental Tendencies ruffle more than a
few feathers but what fans may not know
is that Plaza hilariously caused some
chaos off-screen too while filming the
White Lotus Plaza pulled some pretty
extravagant pranks on her co-stars which
he referred to as a Charlie Kaufman
experiment during an interview with GQ
at one point she collected all the
diffusers scattered around the hotel and
arranged them into a creepy pattern in
the dressing room of co-star Adam
DeMarco who played Alby of Plaza's
Antics DeMarco told G EQ I was
definitely questioning my reality for a
while there I didn't know who to trust
it was like murder on the Orient Express
everyone was the murderer the Child's
Play Star even went so far as to mess up
her own dressing room to deflect blame
convincing the other actors that she had
nothing to do with the pranks the
setting of The White Lotus season 1 is
utterly breathtaking shot on location at
the Four Seasons Resort in Maui episodes
feature pristine Blue Water fluffy white
beaches and picturesque palm trees while
the setting was undeniably beautiful the
location could actually get pretty
distracting at times for instance
Natasha Rothwell who plays Belinda in
the Show's first season revealed that
some of Maui's features often made it
difficult to concentrate when the
cameras were rolling the actor recounted
a particular scene she filmed on a boat
alongside Jennifer Coolidge who plays an
extremely wealthy guest named Tanya
during the scene Tanya scatters her
mother's ashes off the side of the boat
I brought my mother's ashes with me
I could spread them in the ocean however
while filming Rothwell found herself
becoming distracted by the fascinating
sea life surrounding them including some
whales as Rothwell told The Hollywood
Reporter I'm trying to be in the scene
but there's a whale breaching and it was
just magical it was Unreal
season 2 of The White Lotus is filled to
the brim with actions that may or may
not have secret meanings one of the most
fascinating examples of this is when
Cameron played by Theo James kisses his
former college roommate Ethan played by
Will sharp on the cheek the cheek
kissing adds some depth to Cameron and
Ethan's relationship which is extra fun
given the fact that the first one was
actually improvised in an interview with
variety sharp revealed that the cheek
kisses weren't planned recalling those
party scenes were actually very Loosely
scripted it was really improvisatory and
they would cut it in the edit and use
the most helpful bits there has been a
lot of speculation about why Cameron
kisses his friend so often on Reddit
some people are convinced that they're
more than just friends which might
explain why Ethan and his wife Harper
don't have sex but sharp has a different
interpretation of the action telling
variety I think it's Cameron's way of
being playful and sexually voracious and
showing who's boss in this weird way
it's like a micro Power Play Jennifer
coolidge's character Tanya an alcoholic
grieving the recent death of her mother
instantly became a fan favorite the
actor's performance in the White Lotus
was so well received that it earned
Coolidge her first ever Emmy Award in
2022 but what some people may not know
is that coolidge's iconic performances
Tanya almost didn't happen in an
interview with the guardian the actor
revealed I was really affected by the
pandemic I was reading tragic news
stories on a daily basis I knew people
who lost their lives and was convinced
we wouldn't make it through I wasn't
thinking about work because I didn't
think we'd be alive things changed
however when Creator Mike White called
her up and said he'd written a role for
her Coolidge was surprised when white
told her that they'd be filming right
away and that she needed to hop on a
plane to Hawaii however Coolidge wasn't
so sure telling the guardian I'd been
gorging and self-destructing at home for
months eating pizza all day there was no
way I wanted to be on film despite her
reservations about the project the
Legally Blonde star eventually signed up
and ended up becoming one of the show's
standout characters the fact that
Coolidge almost turned down her role in
The White Lotus makes her performance
all the more special as she told the
guard I can't tell you how close I came
to ruining this whole thing for myself
so let's have fun okay
the White Lotus can get pretty risque at
times after all the show features
honeymooning couples and extramarital
Affairs of Plenty it might come as a
surprise then that the show's writer and
Creator Mike White isn't the biggest fan
of shooting these intimate moments in an
interview with NPR white admitted there
were definitely times on this shoot that
I was like what have I got myself into
my threshold for awkwardness is very low
luckily for him the show's actors were
uninhibited which made the entire
filming process much easier as the
enlightened writer told NPR that was new
terrain for me it just felt like it was
important because it really is baked
into the narrative
in season one of the White Lotus Steve
zahn's character neurotic dad Mark
mossbacker has a full frontal nude scene
fearing that he has testicular cancer he
shows his wife Nicole played by Connie
Britton his symptoms zonn actually wore
a prosthetic penis for the shoot and got
to approve the appendage himself despite
being shocked by the scenes on told GQ
it's so abrupt the way Mike White did it
was just great it's like bam first
episode so HBO isn't it season two of
The White Lotus is also filled with wild
and shocking moments one of the most
surprising scenes is the one in which
Cameron gets naked after the episode
aired viewers quickly took to Twitter to
discuss whether or not Theo James was
wearing a prosthetic penis on screen
fans finally got their answer when James
revealed that likes on in season 1 he
was actually wearing a prosthetic joking
about the size of the fake appendage
James said on The Tonight Show starring
Jimmy Fallon the thing is ginormous and
being the director Mike White are
sitting there going that's average
in the second season of the White Lotus
Haley Lou Richardson plays Porsha
Tanya's gen Z assistant quickly
Porsche's colorful idiosyncratic outfits
became one of the most discussed things
about the White Lotus each episode many
fans have critiqued the outfits with one
Twitter user writing Porsche gave us one
cute outfit now she's back to dressing
like a Polly Pocket doll who lost half
her luggage another user painfully noted
Porsche's outfits always look like a
toddler got dressed and demanded to wear
very random and specific things together
Alex Bovaird who has served as the
costume designer for both seasons of The
White Lotus revealed that there is a
reason Porsche dress is the way she does
in an interview with people she
explained my inspiration was from
research online Instagram and also in
person at coffee shops and other
Hangouts in the kind of neighborhoods
Porsha would live in in Los Angeles like
Highland Park there's nothing like
actually going to the places my
characters would actually exist in and
soaking up the fashion Megan Fahey who
plays Cameron's wife Daphne in season 2
of The White Lotus has quickly risen two
fan favorite status since making her
debut on the show what some fans might
not know is that Fahey was originally
gunning for the role of Rachel in season
one of the White Lotus which ultimately
went to Alexandra Daddario she was
undoubtedly disappointed about not
getting the role but Fahey admitted that
it was probably the right choice telling
women's wear daily the thing that
Creator Mike White does so well is that
he always casts the perfect person and
you watch the show and you're like I
can't imagine that being anyone else he
just has a knack for knowing exactly who
the person is
in season one of the White Lotus Mark
discovers that his late father was gay
this is an interesting narrative Arc for
Mark but more than that it actually
Bears similarities to Creator Mike
White's own life
he had two lives
he had his family
and then he had another life his dad Mel
White was an Evangelical Pastor who
ghost wrote for figures such as
religious broadcaster Pat Robertson and
Evangelist Billy Graham due to his
association with right-wing politics it
probably came as a surprise to many when
Mel came out as gay in 1993. he
subsequently became an activist and
wrote a book called stranger at the gate
to be gay and Christian in America Mike
White is clearly close with his father
after winning the Emmy Award for
outstanding directing for a limited
series for the first season of The White
Lotus he gave a shout out to his parents
saying I love my parents my mom let me
be the weird kid that I wanted to be and
my dad who's struggling right now thank
you so much for letting me honor him
tonight
season one of the White Lotus was shot
under the restrictive umbrella of covet
19. and while that likely came with a
lot of frustrating red tape it also had
its benefits as Alexandra Daddario
explained to Forbes it was amazing to
get to do what I love to do with such
incredible people and I think the focus
on health and the world around us made
us appreciate what we were doing so much
more Daddario also noted that the entire
cast was forced to lean on each other
when times got tough during the shoot
telling Forbes there was gratitude and
also the pain of being quarantined from
family and friends so we all supported
each other and helped each other while
also feeling immense joy and gratitude
appreciation for her cast mates wasn't
the only thing that Daddario developed
during the pandemic she revealed that
after wearing mostly sweats and pajamas
for more than a year getting to wear
glamorous outfits on the White Lotus was
a real treat she explained I have a
newfound appreciation for style and
getting dressed up when it comes to the
White Lotus part of the fun is that each
season takes place in a new location
rumor has it that season 3 which has
already been ordered by HBO will take
place somewhere in Asia in October 2022
Mike White told deadline I think it'd be
fun to maybe go to a whole different
continent you know we did Europe and
maybe Asia something crazy like that
that would be fun costume designer Alex
Bovaird seemed to agree with white
telling people I've seen in interviews
that Mike has said he has his eye on
somewhere in Asia for season three so
I'll just say somewhere like Japan while
there's no concrete info on the White
Lotus season 3 just yet there's some
reason to believe that Connie Britton
may be reprising her season one role as
Nicole the Friday Night Live star told
deadline Mike White wanted me to be in
the second season and there was an idea
that I loved for the character Our
intention is to do it in the third
season a piece of casting didn't work in
the second season I would love to see a
spin-off on every character in that show
if the White Lotus keeps on earning rave
reviews there's no telling how many
seasons we might end up with
foreign